- [Narrator] Once you find
out what it is that moves
and shakes you don't want
to do or be anything else.
And though I lost my ability to speak,
I never lost my voice.
So I'm a filmmaker with
motor neuron disease.
- [Woman] How long have
have I been asleep?
Where have I been?
And nothing is recognizable.
- [Narrator] Eight years
ago, Simon Fitzmaurice
was an up-and-coming film director.
(gentle instrumental music)
But just as his career was taking off,
he was diagnosed with motor
neuron disease, or MND,
a degenerative condition
also known as ALS.
Doctors told him he had
only four years to live.
- [Simon] Every profession is inconvenient
to motor neuron disease.
But we don't choose what
moves us, what drives us,
it chooses us.
It's up to you what you
choose to do about it.
- [Narrator] He chose
to fight his diagnosis.
He learned to speak through a
computer and went on to write
and direct his first feature film.
- [Simon] When all this
happened, it was my writing
that saved me.
Like writing, the passion
of film has never left me.
‘My Name is Emily’ is both
of my passions combined.
So MND made me even more
determined to direct this film.
MND is defined by loss,
by what it takes away.
But this was me taking something back.
I can write the
script, I can storyboard,
choose frames with my DP.
I can make all the hundreds of decisions
that comprise this job.
The biggest challenge
in filmmaking that comes
with MND is time.
When I'm on set, there's
a short delay while I type
up my thoughts.
I overcome this by preparing
as much as possible
in advance of the shoot.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Simon and his
wife have had three children
since his diagnosis.
He says he wants to keep
creating to show his children
the importance of never giving up.
- [Simon] When you love films as I do,
you simply want to
contribute, to add my voice
to the art form I love.
I once thought of MND as
a prison camp to which
no liberating army would ever come.
But I outgrew the prison.
I am free.